okay today i'm going to talk to you
about alkali metals
so if i was to look at the periodic
table we can see that the alkali metals
are here in group one
of the periodic table so on the left
hand side of the periodic table
i've actually written them down here so
we can see them nice and clearly they
are lithium
sodium potassium rubidium cesium and
francium so because they're in group one
of the periodic table the key of bit of
information we need to know
is they have one electron
in the outer shell
because they all have one electron in
the uh in the outer shell it means
they all have similar chemical
properties
and there's another video that will show
about how alkali metals react
compared to other metals
they have lower melting
and boiling points so slightly difficult
uh sorry different physical properties
so they're not like a lot of other
metals another reason why they're not
like a lot of other metals
is they're very soft you can actually
cut them with a knife which is very very
um peculiar compared to lots of the
other metals on the periodic table
so let's have a little look at the
reactivity as we go down the group
the least reactive
is lithium at the very top of group one
as you go down the group each
metal each alkali metal becomes more and
more reactive
the most reactive one is francium down
at the bottom which is extremely
extremely reactive
so we need to know why is it that as you
go down the group
reactivity increases so what we're gonna
do is we're just going to have a look at
the difference just between
lithium and sodium lithium is less
reactive than sodium
so if i look at the um the atomic number
here
i can see that lithium has three
electrons
so i'm just going to draw it here so
there's
two electrons in the first shell and one
electron in the outer shell so here
is lithium now lithium is the least
reactive
of all of the alkali metals and here's
why
in order to form an ion because all of
these alkali metals are only involved in
ionic compounds and not
covalent compounds so they need to lose
an electron so that electron needs to be
lost and given to another atom
so in order to do that let's just have a
think about what needs to happen
now these electrons have a negative
charge so electrons remember they are
negative
so in order to draw this away
basically this needs to be pulled kind
of completely attracted away from the
atom
now remember in the nucleus of an atom
we have protons
so in the nucleus this is where we have
our positive protons
now we need to i'll introduce you to a
new term here which is
atomic radius now the atomic radius is
the distance
from the center center of the atom to
the outer electron
because lithium isn't a particularly big
atom there is a small atomic radius
which means there's quite a strong
attraction
between the nucleus and this outer
electron
therefore it's not particularly easy for
this
electron to be lost so this is what's
happening
when lithium forms an ion it starts off
as an
atom then we form a lithium ion
and we have an electron
so let's have a look at this compared to
sodium
which is slightly more reactive than
the uh than lithium so if i look at the
atomic number here i can see that it has
11 electrons so i'll just draw this
quickly
one two three four five
six seven eight nine ten
and eleven so this here
is sodium now because it has one
electron in the outer shell it too
is looking to lose an electron in order
to form an
ion like this so again it starts as an
atom
and it has now formed an ion
let's have a look at the difference in
atomic radius
remember atomic rate is the distance
from the center part of the atom to the
outer electron
the atomic radius is much bigger
in sodium compared to lithium so
therefore there's a smaller attraction
between the positive protons in the
nucleus
and this negative electron therefore
it's easier for this electron
to be lost and remember
as you go down the group that atomic
radius is going to get
bigger and bigger and bigger so it's
become easier and easier and easier to
lose that electron
therefore the bottom ones are much much
more reactive
so this is why
these um alkali metals form parts of
ionic compounds because they lose
that outer electron thank you